the collapse of the Silicon Valley sperm
bank was a valley
we literally got there one two three
guys fairy crafts clothes that feel as
good as the day at the beach we know we
have all the fairy clothes and they are
backed by their guarantee of quality
summer starts with Verity look good and
stay cool with effortless warm weather
styles with their tees shorts swim we
have all these things swim and more
you'll be ready for whatever season this
season throws and I love this started by
twin brothers Alex and Mike in 2013 as a
beach house on Wheels the brand is now
celebrating 10 years of great clothes
and Good Vibes this year their ongoing
partnership with Native designer
supports native communities while
helping and appropriation in fashion
every piece piece is designed to be a
lifetime favorite and if anything
happens along the way faradi will
replace or fix close your clothes for
life no matter what I love this stuff
and you talk about the Native American
collection I've got so many of those
long sleeve shirts and Native American
shirts I just wore up in Alaska people
were like where'd you get this that the
Native American fleece the good feather
fleeces his clothes are comfortable they
look good you can dress them up you can
wear them down if you just want to be
casual they kind of span the Spectrum
you always feel comfortable and good
there I always say these are the kind of
clothes you want to travel in because
they're your most comfortable clothes
and then you can go off the plane and
out for the night in these clothes and
that's what makes them so special just
great designs really and they're a
family business and it's Twins and Randy
and I know these guys personally we love
their brand I'm going to say this the
all day short that they have which I
also can double as a swimsuit which is
incredible uh just their stuff is
functional as well too you were going to
say Jay they're twin brothers we really
it's a family business we appreciate how
much they love each other and how much
their families have rallied around it
and they love this show they sponsor the
show so support them because they
support us and Verity is giving all dumb
people Town listeners an amazing deal 20
off your order damn yep head to
veritybrand.com DPT and use the code
dpt20 that's dpt2 2-0 at checkout hey
guys I want to talk to you about
electric e-bikes
incredible I don't know if you've ever
driven uh or ridden an uh electric bike
and specifically electric e-bike yeah
they are incredible they're designed so
well they're really cool easy to and
they make everything fun I mean from
Quick store trips to Outdoor Adventures
electric e-bikes created a mode of
transportation that anyone can ride even
your dad so Father's Day right around
the corner let's get on this people yeah
give them something that he's really
gonna love the charges last so long on
these you can get around you can have so
much fun they're just really like the
best most fun way to travel in your
neighborhood or out in the wilderness uh
they include rides from the efforts
effortlessly fun XP Lite to a highly
capable cargo e-bike called the
Expedition yeah NJ the cost is less it's
so much less than the competition these
are foldable they ship free they come
fully assessed assembled so you don't
have to like sit there for days and try
to put it together this is a right out
of the box and you're on the road and
you're having so I love this idea as a
gift for Dad so celebrate your debt give
him the freedom that comes with electric
e-bike visit
electricebikes.com to learn more and
explore the Epic models electric has to
offer that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com check it out
hey downies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population U
population Walsh Maddie move your car
walls your man your man under the bus
Matt Walsh
you told us that story on this show back
in like 2017. yeah that was a terrifying
terrified me uh bad choice and I shared
that I don't think I've shared that
anywhere else you were going in to like
check your luggage and then you laid
down underneath
hitchhiking and on Yugoslavia some
country and I try I broke in English I'm
like I need to get and he's like I got
no seats but you can go here and he
lifted up and his pillow was down there
in a book and a light and he seems like
he used it so I'm like fine I'll do it
and for the next three or four hours I
was trapped underneath the bus and just
losing my mind terrified that's like a
coffin that is like that is like I'm
sorry all I could think of the car the
bus rolling in the and they get everyone
off and they go all right just trash it
yeah there's nobody left on the bus yeah
washer and you're just like oh God I
don't know I couldn't ride in the arch I
got out of the Pod with them I was like
I'm not doing this yeah have you ridden
to the top of the arch you know I don't
think I have St Louis they keep calling
it an elevator it is
like nope I know my limitations yeah I'm
with you I don't know that I would uh
well here's the good news that since
that time that you were on this show and
you're back on the show you got a new
podcast we'll talk about all that stuff
can't wait little Ziggy scar dust on my
lap a birthday cake over here birthday
cake over here so may is the gauntlet of
birthdays we have Mother's Day then
Morgan's birthday then Jude's birthday
today and then uh Emmy's birthday in
about a week and that is a cake actually
that because it has coconut nobody was
going to eat it so it was an extra cake
so the kids said can we hit the extra
cake to try it and then we have a cake
coming tonight so I'm like I'll just
bring it on the show for A Conversation
Piece I'm not gonna make anyone eat it
no but they're in the middle but I did
bring plates and forks 100 news is that
as dumb as that cake is it's not even as
close to as dumb as the world has gotten
oh my God continues to be done
continuously dumb stories continue to
get sent to us Jay's got the first one
and there's a new way that we do it Dan
had all the stories last time we each
get to do a story this time me and Jason
again so Jason you still are in the
position of just uh goofing on just
relax okay so uh I'll do this was sent
in by Carlene McDermott Charlie Carlene
one of our favorite bands she's like a
Stringer for us at this point yeah she's
a research Department onto herself she
finds him and there is a question in the
in the uh in the headline so I will try
my best not to reveal okay like Dan's so
good for years and years of doing it he
knows exactly what to gloss over because
it might be a guessing game later yeah
we'll be like so anyway this 32 year old
wait no why did I do that all right so
prolific sperm donor reveals he doesn't
have a sex life despite fathering a ton
of kids a bunch of kids and we'll guess
how many okay all right A Serial sperm
donor because it's not really the same
thing cereal cereal sperm donor yeah if
you do it frequently on a regular basis
I mean I guess if a hobby to
counterbalance a serial killer someone's
telling me that there aren't any serial
killers there's one in Austin right now
I know someone's trying to some people
say because the internet and television
has made serial killers more educated
about how to get away with it oh there's
so much True Crime and yeah things that
people get caught with yeah that and
serial killers are still out there right
they're just they're more schooled and
unless they have that compulsion to like
wannabe or like you know that like like
the Zodiac had that even though I didn't
catch them but like where they want to
engage with the cops and what like they
or they're not willing to pay for cable
right right right the streamers yeah
that's the real problem
if you own and I'm not into podcasts oh
well you would learn a podcast
uh the man has followed father and
multiple children around the globe and
has revealed that his second Globe
around the globe is non-existent well I
mean he doesn't have to travel around
the globe just his mom can travel around
the globe can you mail it can you ship
sperm sure no some dry out you got to be
in the bank you can get a pizza from
Chicago yeah I mean that's a great Point
yeah what's it called gold belly or
whatever yeah I love Gold Belts Jay
loves gold belly I get bagels from
Queens off of gold belly the best I've
ever had Utopia India is that weird you
have to I didn't none of you have done a
sperm bank I haven't done a sperm bank I
don't know if any of those no I'm sure
we know somebody who has without whether
we know it or not but you I think you
have to be in the bank
yeah so he's had to go around the world
with the antenna the Silicon Valley the
collapse of the Silicon Valley sperm
bank was in that way
we literally got there one two three
uh he claimed okay so he's that
committed to helping others yeah he
claims that while he is being altruistic
he feels that his life has become
robotic and that masturbation has become
a chore so who did that to you who put a
gun to your head and said you go you put
a gun to your penis and they said you go
do this nobody that's what they call the
golden handcuffs you got good money yeah
but you're not happy right I mean that's
the golden hand job
uh Kyle Gordy and I won't tell you his
name he's from California Kyle Guardian
Kyle gordian no Kyle's live past 50. is
that what he said yeah there's no old
Kyles you know Kylie's 86 no I don't
right there is no old either he says
like you either die in a skateboarding
accident or murdered but you're not
there's no old Kyles the other thing in
Texas where they gathered all Kyle's to
have the world record for the most shut
up this past weekend no way come on yeah
gather the most people the same name in
one city and it was you had to have Kyle
as your legit first name on some
certified ID was it Kyle Texas I don't
it might have been I don't know Kyle
Texas that's still appropriate oh well
this is caught at Kyle Gordy one two
three four wait you're plugging him I am
on Instagram uh he's raked up followers
online for his controversial hobby as a
sperm business followers than children
that's my question oh no it probably
does no no
followers than children did you look at
his followers he has more followers than
Joe yeah
in a bid to help to help struggling
families he offers his services for free
and has revealed that he is often
inundated with messages from women who
want to have his kids so this has got to
be an ego thing right yeah yeah you he
likes people can we get the stats on
this guy like D1 what is he we're gonna
is he because he's offering it free is
he his own bank or is he still going
through a I think I'm aggregate of sperm
I bet he's his own bank that's even
shadier oh yeah like it's an arrangement
what's the condition which means he's
probably
how strong is his that's a good question
too uh he's probably got that Baratheon
seed okay previous Game of Thrones
I got it he oh I don't watch Game of
Thrones uh never seen it not once not
once and even I know that the ending was
disappointing yeah well you know what
it's Game of Thrones just get just sit
back and watch it Jay you've never seen
it don't complain about the last season
they gave us the greatest shows you've
never seen it and you think the last
episode did you know they just did like
a battle of the bastards like Game of
Thrones live Symphony thing it's a it's
insane it was just like the most people
on a second what did it feel like what
do you think it was like the last the
last episode like and you've never seen
even a second of this
like this is like Cisco and brother and
a brother and sister having sex and
getting pushed out of a window you've
never seen it it's like season one
uh all right uh uh here we go uh
previously he opened up how he's been
trying new methods of donating his
tadpoles through in vitro first they
said that yeah yeah and in a
collaboration with an IVF clinic in the
Philippines okay where are you getting
your IVF from you know down the
Philippines well that seems like it just
feels convenient like that in case
anything goes wrong they're really easy
to contact so he's shipping it to him
he's outsourced
he said uh he hit that his light his sex
life has become non-existent yeah due to
his Goodwill gesture of helping others
and that the practice as well as the
masturbation has become a chore hey what
do you do what's his name stop Kyle yeah
Kyle nobody's got a gun to your head
yeah what are you doing this weekend
making more people he said I think I've
masturbated so many times now it started
to feel quite robotic and repetitive
what are you 14 a 14 year old it doesn't
feel that's true a robotic for them I
don't have any pity for him you can
leave anytime right you can you think
this guy's 32 or 72. I bet he's we're
gonna get I know but I'm already feeling
it correction you can jerk off anytime
you like but you can never really
[Music]
I hear you uh I don't have a sex life
outside of donating it's completely nice
resistant as one of the reasons I don't
go out and have sex is because I want to
save it up and give the best possible
chance for pregnant you're a martyr
you're a jerk off martyr you're a
population being like everybody the
world's conspiring against your sperm
yeah I wish I didn't have to do this you
don't
yeah you don't I have no sympathy I
abstain until I donate so I can build up
my sperm count and release it upon
donating for best success I also don't
want to risk having sex with random
women and getting an STD so there's lots
of responsibility on my shoulders and
I'm not going to take any chances no
there's not you can't impose somebody my
mom would like try to make a big deal
out of something and then [__] about
how she had to do all this work and I'm
like mother I love you but you signed up
for this on the sheet you created right
I gotta take all these you got to tell
me the name of the baskets because I
don't know longer burger basket I gotta
get all these longer burger baskets I
gotta take them all back and return them
well who got them I did you got them
dinner is taking nine hours I said we
could order in
sketch in the hot dog we all are going
to try to figure out who did this you
before I used to date and have sex but I
chose to give it up to help other women
and their families but it's all become
so robotic now I don't have the need to
do either in my own time I prefer
traveling over donating and that's now
my main hobby but I'll continue doing
this for as long as women need me he
thinks he's a superhero women women need
me all over this globe Matt
uh there's a lot of people who would
probably give their seed for free yeah
exactly also the first question for this
guy if you are looking for a donor is
are you a narcissist yeah because yeah
and this answer is yes and that's
actually a trait you don't want it in
your child a delusional thinking
narcissist something you don't want in
your child that's a vote for not take
don't take this guy don't take the free
one there's a reason it's free guess
what comes with it narcissist nothing is
wrong from a guy who's like I don't know
we'll see what happens
I'm sorry curious about those traits
like is he intelligent cute tall right
it's a good beard looking and that's
right in order to ensure that he's fully
focused on his Newfound passion cause
revealed that he is he no longer travels
across the globe just to donate now he
expresses that he's more willing to help
potential clients if they travel to him
wherever he's chosen to go sightseeing
he's also started to ask more questions
to other people he donates to to ensure
that they will be good parents to his
child it's not your child that's not
your kid it is not your kid it's done
you don't get to ask me what I'm gonna
be at Mount Rushmore in June I'll find a
bathroom in the state park
you don't get to ask me
checking out at Kohl's this isn't your
responsibility I'm asking questions
about their work Mental Health financial
situation and parenting attitudes as
long as the women ticks the boxes and
can care for the child without any
issues then I will happily help I think
this guy is gaslighting me okay I'm
sorry this guy has a God complex right
he's like I I've created these
population in my own image sure yeah
yeah he probably talks about how he
almost joined the military oh yeah he's
chalked up his Tip-Top sperm to uh his
updated daily routine saying I've been
sleeping a lot more recently especially
during winter I think a good sleep what
do you hibernate good sleep helps
someone interviewed basketball I reckon
I'm sleeping about 10 hours per day
sometimes more if needed avoiding stress
where possible has also helped with my
sperm how do you know yeah
next month there are how many more women
who are interested in him donating wait
you're having us guess yeah just guess
he's in the next how many lined up for
next week
30. can you do One A Day what do you
think I'm gonna go 100 well he's acting
like he can I'm gonna say a hundred oh
my God yeah you can jerk it up 30 100
but if he's doing
3.3 times a day yeah he's he has to be
young no way he would have to be you
can't refill a fertile batch of semen no
that I'm gonna say I'm gonna say he has
22.
I like that's probably a smart I guess
it's only three but still but he's very
selective now all right while his dating
life is non-existent existing College
amenities open to a relationship and
kids with the right person although she
would have to accept his unique hobby so
he's like I'm not when I meet my wife
I'm not going to stop
making kids for other people and by the
way I already don't want to have sex
yeah right yeah that's like having a
third person in the marriage
yeah right you're saving a lot of
yourself like what wife would accept
that none of our wives would accept that
none of our wives not for one minute I'm
not going to where to meet someone to
give them drop off your own seat wait
you want me to help you judge If This
Woman's fit to raise your baby honey no
did you book my tickets on Expedia wait
now she's booking I'm going to the Great
Wall of beating four people and I have
to jerk off four times to be honest with
you guys part of me thinks I can fix it
I can't I can get it and there is
someone there is someone out there I can
get him to stop I'll be the one where he
only gives his sperm to me watch watch
Becky watch me Becky I can do this uh
previously he revealed how he helped
women in the Ukraine conceive her child
uh so now
[Music]
for making my dreams come true we're
gonna have two guesses on this okay punk
ass [__]
um wow how many children has he sired
let's start there and it's true he sired
secretary can I ask how long he's been
doing it or we don't know uh he did I
don't know but I feel like age would
give us an idea do you want to do Age
first
which do you want to do first two Age
first because all right what do you
think he's 30. so I'll say 36 36 I was
gonna say 39.
it's definitely not 20s no no I'm gonna
go 48 years old no 48 years old okay
good this is the end
this
this month but he still feels this
responsibility he's made this his whole
identity right this is his identity
you're right yeah yeah this is like this
is like those people with bumper
stickers it feels like his whole
identity so I asked this all the time it
when you get it you like the National
Party when you meet somebody new at a at
a party what's the first thing you say
about yourself I'm from Rochelle
Illinois about me yes like if someone's
like hey this is my friend so and so and
they don't know you from TV or stuff
you've done what's the first thing you
say about yourself that's a great I
don't know I can't I don't have a
standard go-to well I'll ask you now and
I'll just say hey man we're at a party
yeah hey I say my name Matt and what do
you what's I I say what are you into
tell me something about yourself tell me
something about uh I live in Toluca Lake
yeah you gotta drink it I got some kids
I'm a dad a dad so I think Dad's maybe
first where are you from I'm from
Chicago obviously Chicago it's always a
good conversation well it's just like
usually it's led by a question right
I'm more like how do you who do you know
here you know I'm always like trying to
get one connection yeah how do you know
the birthday boy like that would be you
guys are you guys are quick to like
sports we just met a bunch of people in
Alaska and it was I think I say like I'm
originally from St Louis I have kids I
have a twin brother like I'd start with
those kind of things and I maybe say I
do comedy okay yeah all right that's
probably in the range yeah all those
things this guy is definitely like I
donate sperm like that's the beginning
and end no I'll tell you exactly how
many kids he's made yeah yeah have you
made any kit I mean you know 36 39 I say
30 48. yeah yeah get your answers in
because this [__] is 31 years
old oh my original and you were right
yeah he's been working overtime how many
children will end Story number one on
this how many children has he signed he
can't be more than 10 years in right I
mean he could be 31 that'd be around 10
years in he's got three lined up for the
next month but he's also kind of he's
got he's got we'll say 350 yeah 350.
he's got half a shaft out of the game so
that's high I'm gonna go down I'm gonna
say three oh one yeah just to make the
number Price is Right yeah
I guess I'm gonna say uh 250 250. that's
a better guess
he might have 500 oh I'll go 100 100 I
know but you know I don't like that
because it's definitely not going to be
a hundred no okay I'll I'll go 86. 86
good all right
get your answers in okay thank you
Colleen McDermott thank you Carly mcder
this guy has Kyle has sired 57 children
wow Daniel is still alive you're really
you're close but it's 57 it's still a
lot of kids yes four is a lot of kids
like that's like one you said you were
you you had six brothers and sisters yes
that's a lot of kids that's one LAUSD
classroom full of kids yeah it is 57.
based on the percentage of how well you
are in tune with what your kids are up
to what percentage of your childhood do
you think your parents had no idea where
you were uh what percentage of what your
childhood do you think your parents had
no idea what I mean are both of our
parents because it's so different now
but my generation your guys's generation
there was a lot of time left yeah my mom
had no and it's six seven kids you're
relying on other kids to be like don't
let them jump on rocks you guys were
taking care of you
40 to 50 percent yes no idea like a
rough idea
that guy comes to me at a party he says
yeah I've been doing it for 12 years and
he throws out the number 56. you would
definitely try a message I would be like
I'm not impressed right only 56 12 years
come on barely five a year yeah barely
five a year sounds like you're not in
that big a demand Matt Walsh should be
like are you are you taking a lot of
time off between them did you have a
injury in there were you on the IR for a
while sorry do you have carpal tunnel
because I pulled something because he's
so self-important like well people are
constantly asking so he's going to argue
so you know what he's going to say back
to you to try and one-up you in that in
that moment I'm selected yeah I I don't
just give it to anyone it's not about
how many of you refused is my next
question it's not about quantity
quality
yeah I I'll if someone if there's
someone I meet and I like them at first
and then they don't like me I'll jerk
off onto the
all right there you go Story number one
down the books when we come back hey
guess what Matt Walsh has a new podcast
let's go the great Tim Simons I'm so
excited about this we'll talk all about
it on the other side of the break Dan's
got the next story it's dumb people town
with Matt Walsh don't go anywhere
hey townies welcome back to dumb people
town uh we are so happy to be back
Daniel's eating literally eating the
cake is that breakfast Dan is here
that's a Costco cake there's supposedly
a little coconut in there but I didn't
really taste it
that's why the kids Morgan read the
ingredients she's like coconut nobody's
gonna eat it I'm like all right so he's
basically having his cake and eating it
too yeah damn do you notice how their
kids took the balloons off by the way
the frosting balloons are taken by the
way and sometimes you need a good
Ralph's Ralph's the Ralph's sheet cake
is all good that's how you get through a
market sheet cake because they're like
we don't care that we're did you just
gloss over Dan's great comment that's
how you get over a break that's how you
get through a breakup
dude 100 you know I love it I mean that
is how you get over a breakup but
they're just not afraid to use like food
coloring that's like been bang oh yeah
it's not good for you but it's been
baked no all that has like radon in it
sometimes your heart hurts so bad you
have to eat yesterday's cake before we
get into Dan's story uh let's do a quick
run around the room and just let people
know what we have where are you guys
gonna be so uh we were by the way we're
just in Minneapolis I don't know when
this is going to drop we were just in
Minneapolis great shows at Acme Comedy
Company what are the best amazing City
great and we got to be with our buddy
Nate Abshire he you know what he did for
us he threw a barbecue for us and it was
like the whole Minneapolis come his all
the comedy scenes and the the young
Comedians and stuff we all kind of hung
out and had a barbecue it was so nice
and then we were in Alaska which was
really cool uh we're going to San
Francisco at the end of July of doing
cops comedy club for two nights just a
Friday and Saturday 21st and 22nd uh
we're doing a show at uh The Comedy
Store on June 14th 14th we're doing tag
it which is a great show you will love
this and you'll be like this is the
essence of you guys so the premises what
you say to people this is their entire
relationship with every comic when they
get off stage now they're doing it on
stage so comic tests are set Randy and I
are off to the side as they're doing it
we're quickly writing improvising tags
for their whole set we keep them on
stage and we pitch them all the tags and
they can take them away with them and
yeah
have used and like script doctors kind
of
punch-ups but like on the Fly you know
what's funny when I watch stand up I
often want to give people that but I
don't want to offend right so we think
that too like I don't have an ego about
it like I'm not better than you but I
like you guys I can watch something oh
you there's so much here you didn't even
dig it so the way we approach it it's
such a great point the way we approach
it is hey I love this bit you were doing
here and in my mind I thought you were
gonna go this way which by the way
whatever you're doing but what if you
took it this way this is my pitch to you
take it or leave it we always are like
take it or leave it that's a great
Workshop I love that it's really fun and
it's a huge it's like a very it's
exciting but like we're on the spot the
whole night because you know if we just
Jessica gets to see a glimpse of what
happens in The Green Room and so many
different you guys are good writers
thank you very good thank you and we
love a tag and we love Joe and by the
way so many different styles so aparna
is going to be on the show and uh Doug
Benson is going to be on the show and I
mean Ian in Edwards is going to be on
the show so very different kinds I was
in town I would just come to watch
that's a great feeling that's on June
14th June 14th all uh Super squads.com
Daniel where can they catch you uh dates
are going to be announced this summer
but you can also check out my show every
other Monday it's called best bet comedy
we did it's my show that I do along with
the great comic Irene II I don't really
know when this is going to drop but go
to Daniel vancouver.com or follow best
bet comedy on Instagram or myself and I
think I'm coming to like
yeah like where the 101 meets Melrose uh
but I got stuff uh coming up how much
dates in the midwest New York Boston and
Austin all that stuff's gonna be
announced soon go to danielvankirk.com
let's talk about your Show podcast with
Tim Simons it's coming back uh Tim
Simons and I did a podcast called second
in command and we're gonna go through
every episode of Veep and bring on all
our friends from the show and we took
like a year off because we were very
disorganized and various reasons and now
we're back here at uh all things comedy
and we just uh launched it like a week
ago so check out second second in
command uh at all things comedy how does
it feel going back and re-watching like
even especially like the evolution of
your character and a certainly uh what
happens to Jonah and like yeah yeah it's
a lot easier to watch something as an
actor when there's like years yeah since
you made it because you can actually
watch the whole show and you're not
focusing in securely on what you did
wrong or how you look you know what I
mean yeah it's enjoyable have you guys
gotten to one one of my favorite things
the show I love but talking to you about
the show is when you guys would tell me
you would tell me you guys would do like
Marathon page days yeah like didn't you
do 36 Pages yeah there was a show in
season two with Allison Janney where we
were in a house and I think it was like
40 it was like 40 plus for people who
don't know if you get through three
pages in a day ten ten is like the most
but I'm saying sometimes even just a
setup can be like yeah yeah like on a
movie like three to six is right kind of
normal that's maybe maybe 10 or 12 right
yeah 10 is a lot I mean depends how many
cameras you got four minute if you're
moving fast yeah 40 pages yeah it was
dirt just shooting it dirty and we had
everything ready and when you guys do
the show do you also talk about your
time in Baltimore where you went and
watched every movie that came out for a
year listen yeah we talk about anything
that uh comes up so we talk about
restaurants
because I remember doing bear down
during like you were back and I go what
have you been doing other than the show
and you go movies
every day because it was like downstairs
from your hotel right working on Veep
for some years we were just living in
the hotel and going to work that was it
like being a stand-up on the road you're
just there to work right and when you
had off time I would just walk
downstairs literally in the building
there was a movie theater and I would
just whatever time I would see any movie
and there's like a year
it's probably like 2013 I probably know
every movie that came out you know what
I mean Ender's Game you name it
I wouldn't see right and and you could
get a drink so it was like I did that
and play Squash yeah you know freaking
beautiful I love it so anyway you're
gonna you can see it here again let
people know the name of it so it's
called second in command second in
command it drops every week yeah every
Tuesday if you love Veep and you want
sort of the inside poop and all the
great memories of two guys who are great
comics and a great listen this is a
podcast for you subscribe to it do it
all right Daniel yeah this one in by Liz
Hagerty at Liz Hagerty thank you Liz a
Colorado man got a back tattoo of the
new Subway series logo you're talking
about Subway the sandwich shop dance
Subway the sandwich oh come on the fact
that they called it the Subways did
Jared make him do it all right when I
saw someone I was like when was the last
subway series uh that was like New York
Mets versus the Yankees but like this is
what Subway calls there we'll get into
it but you know like somebody's getting
killed by Jersey Mike's my favorite
sandwich I agree that's my airport I
hope they're not a sponsor no you know
but we can take who's the other one it's
Jersey Jimmy John Jimmy Johnson there
are Loyals to Jimmy John's yes
University of Illinois certainly North
Chicago free smells when they came out
here was a big deal I can I can mess
with the number 11 at Jimmy John's
that's great but Jersey Mike's just
knows what they're doing Jay and I and
John Glazer when we were working on uh
cheap seats in New York there was across
from the New Yorker Hotel was a Quiznos
and we
went nuts for quick to the point now as
they started closing around the country
wherever we see a Quiznos we'll just
take up the picture of it send it to
glazing just so solid I haven't been to
a Quiznos in your size
toasted they they were so good they
changed the game wow it was like with
hot bellies there it is that's exactly
Potbelly's came out with the melty yeah
the original John Clark yeah really good
sandwich so good all right so
all right yeah here we go Colorado man
has one free Subway sandwiches for life
and it's all thanks to his latest tattoo
Subway recently introduced its new
Subway series menu which consists of 12
new sandwiches sold as is the launch
marks the company's biggest menu
overhaul in its history and is a big
departure from the customization that
made the chain popular which now I
wanted to ask you guys and I thought
about this when I was putting this
together John door and I started a thing
at JFL 42 back in like 2019. I think I
remember where we just asked everybody
what is your Subway order and then they
had an open slot and they asked us if we
wanted to do anything on stage so we did
Welcome to Subway as a show with no prep
but it's John doors so you don't need
anything oh you need is John door yeah
and we the whole thing was just
genuinely asking people and then
we'll ask you guys oh no my kids I I
took them one time we were like on a
family trip driving up to Lake Tahoe and
there's like a Subway right where you
get gas in like in Palmdale right it's
right as you hit the Mojave Desert right
there so like we went into the gas
station got gas and I ordered Subway and
they ordered stuff that like they never
eat they never ate at the house so
they're young kids and they're like I
have a you know a turkey with some
lettuce can I get banana peppers some
Tomatoes no my son's like olives you're
gonna murder me in my sleep are you
living a double life are you someone
else's kid vegetables black olives my
son wants black olives on his Subways
yeah I'm like wait that's why my
daughter likes Subways because they have
olives Jersey Mike's no olives that's
true yeah that's her one preference for
Subway
on her back I mean that's the reason no
but you get a kid's meal if you tattoo
your children that's so just one for
their life not for life no no just one
okay
your kids look like post Malone my dad
wanted a lot of sandwiches they were
offering one sandwich I was hungry got
16 lunches
uh to celebrate Subway hosted a block
party event in Las Vegas no idea why on
Wednesday where fans could get a tattoo
of the new Subway series logo and earn
free sandwiches does it look like the
recycling thing for a month a year or a
lifetime depending on the size and
location on the body that is unreal fans
fans of Subway that's you already I was
out when you said fans
like Matt what tell me a little bit
about yourself
Matt did this or maybe it was more like
a delay of 24 hours like when you buy a
gun
do you know what I mean like there
should be something representative next
to the subway guy do it man I'll give
you free sandwiches hold on hold on you
gotta come back
what if you handed the tattoo and live
with it for a little while it sounds
like they got a wig now I don't know if
besser created this or you or all you
guys were in on it but you know UCB had
this if you got a UCB logo tattoo
glasses you got free to every show
he's the only guy I know who got a UCB
tech there was two people that I never
saw one was a woman and then one was
another guy what a great day we come to
a lot of shows on Tuesdays they would
come to uh comedy Death Race but in our
defense we didn't set up a block party
and have a tattoo artist no but there
was a lot of pressure
you didn't have like an authenticator
forehead tattoo you got a t-shirt
every time you walk through the door
yeah the same shirt
just any shirt we have any more t-shirts
yeah it was a lost and founder
stick around make a sound there's more
to people town
guys we want to say thank you to our
sponsor Verity Verity is amazing it's a
family brand founded by Alex and his
wife Carrie and his twin brother Mike
and it channels their love of the beach
lifestyle into clothing for life's
greatest moments Rarity crafts clothes
that feel as good as a day at the beach
and they're backed by their guarantee of
quality Verity is giving all dumb people
Town listeners an amazing deal 20 off
your order so head to faradaybrand.com
DPT and use the code dpt20 at checkout
for 20 off your order this is great
stuff people Randy and I are dads we
know that dads do a lot for their
families so we say why not give your dad
something that lasts way longer than
dad's day golf or Dad's tie that he puts
in the closet never wears anymore how
about his very own electric e-bike yeah
transform his day-to-day errands into
Fun Carefree Adventure stamp and you can
celebrate your dad and give him all the
freedom that comes with electric e-bike
visit electricebikes.com to learn more
and explore the Epic models electric has
to offer that's
l-e-c-t-r-i-c-e-bikes.com
[Music]
so they host this thing in Vegas uh fans
could do this depending on the size and
location of body they would get it for a
month a year or a lifetime James cunns
oh god
k-u-n-z
he's a Walmart grader right
up top James cunns of Fort Collins
Colorado hey [__] can you grabs we
traveled to Vegas jumped at the chance
he got a tattoo of the logo on his back
burning him Foot Longs for Life awarded
in the form of fifty thousand dollars in
Subway gift cards wow the winning tattoo
is how many square inches
what do you think he went for what's a
square inch something like that yeah
yeah how big is it back I don't know do
you saying it's a Foot Locker one by one
would obviously be two square inches I'm
gonna try and pull this up here because
20. I'll say Twenties
no no that's not too big what do you
want to go with I'm saying 24 square
inches because I think it's two inches
up and 12 I think it's a foot long okay
which they also got sued for yeah I
think it's 40 square inches oh my God
like the whole I hope it isn't the whole
back okay I hope it is 24. what was the
lock in here 20 24 40. okay
I'm going in tattoo crazy in square
interest that got him a Year's worth is
144 square inches this is the photo of
oh my God on his back it's like the
Sublime album look at this he is a
corporate
company name on his back you show away
series you corporate shill quote I might
not have family much else going on I
don't practice sandwich area
I ain't got no toasted meatball I'm a
huge fan of Subway so I thought about it
did you and I thought you didn't think
about anything bro I thought about it
and I thought anybody's saying that
already I thought about it I thought
about it and I thought well maybe I
should fly out to Vegas he said I'm
thrilled to have made it this far not in
life Dan and I this tells me he's got no
one in his life to tell him no no he
needs to know guy you need to know me no
guy or no man no guy I mean a partner
yeah I'm thrilled to have made it this
far and to have actually gotten the big
tattoo I'm proud of it which I say you
better be you bet yeah cunns first heard
about the event in a Twitter group chat
that it that already tells you is there
any is there such a thing
but probably a Subway group chat right
no I bet it's a Subway themed no it's a
DM group chat it's a DM group chat okay
that is a thing whatever he's playing
he's paying for a blue check I can tell
you that one someone shared the news in
there and I thought wow I should do that
because I would love to get free Subway
for life he said this is a simple man
yeah kuns actually credit Subway with
helping him improve his health years ago
to which Subway's probably like look we
are distancing ourselves from people who
have lost weight yeah via our diets
we're on the it's all about the men
units please don't show us your old
paper please do not hold up so our bread
is in bread it's all sugar cons credits
them with helping him improve his health
I used to be a chunky teenager everybody
did and Subway was one of the factors
that helped me change out of a less
healthy fast food diet it helped me
become a lot healthier and well until
yeah right besides cons eight other fans
got three by three inch tattoos of the
subway series logo on a shoulder blade
forearm and calf they won free
sandwiches for a year awarded as how
much money how much money do you think
Subway says this is what granted for
life this is what you need for a year
five grand five grand okay uh let's say
three grand okay
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna say forty five
hundred dollars was it breckenmeyer who
told us that he did a commercial and got
like a Subway Black Card yes he got he
got a black guard he could go in and get
it and that's pretty good he said he's
terrified to use it because he a couple
of the times they look at him like sir
just yeah if you go to an airport one
that's independently owned or not
they recognize they don't even have him
this guy this guy is not gonna pay
airport extensions of chain restaurants
are I went to a Jersey Mike's that
wasn't the only was the only Jersey
Mike's that wasn't good and it was in an
airport yeah the one in Vegas is
questionable it was like Denver or Vegas
I'm in Vegas yeah anything in an airport
is do we have to talk about the American
Airlines uh sports bar at American
Airlines called home turf right no one's
home whose home turf is that right who's
like hey let's go watch the game let's
watch the Bears game this weekend
take it through security
I will say if it is your home turf like
you've landed and now you're drinking
just go get your lunch just go home
my guess was 4 500 because I'm thinking
like
per month they awarded you
four thousand three hundred and eighty
dollars
that was really well done that was so
good to promote this game no I I was
doing the math in my head I was doing I
was doing to promote its newest
sandwiches Subway also gave away one
million free subs from the subway series
earlier this month do they just have
extra ingredients they are just trying
to hold ground
so one is like they probably do the
algorithm if you're gonna eat Subway for
a lifetime we only need to pay for 10
years because you'll probably die right
you'll be dead you'll be dead that's
right this is like the turtle left free
Turtle Wax for a year you're like I
can't get through half a can but I will
say there are times on the road where
it's you find a 24-hour Subway and a
meatball sub or a cold I'm with you I'm
with you there are times where you're
with your kids and they're coming from a
swim practice and you're like no we're
gonna take a McDonald's what are we
gonna do yeah if your choice is
McDonald's or Subway you're like just go
over there and get a turkey sandwich
yeah yeah and I agree to feel better
about ourselves go over and order
something you've never ordered in my
practice actually hold on real quick
we're gonna go in here and get you a
tattoo first and then yeah but if I work
for Jersey Mike's marketing what do you
do have the campaign where we show this
guys back getting lasered off and then
we show them going with our brand
yeah cover it up just says Mike's way
who was it the Sprint guy jumped over to
a t oh yeah you can hear me now can you
hear me now guys like we cared about his
loyalty like
like now I'm like I don't care I didn't
care before it's like as our guy I just
pictured they're hired for a commercial
I just picture the conference room where
someone laid that out and just stormed
out dropping their mic like look who we
look who we got we'll get the subway guy
and we'll tattoo him with our logo
that's Story number no or what they do
is they take the same Subway logo and
then right underneath that they just put
the word sucks
and then a little Jersey Mike's logo
right underneath it feels very Jersey
Mike's right all right that's story too
friends
I got a little do you remember do you
want me to do it I don't remember Daniel
you have a all I see I'm not going to
scroll any further is man arrested after
posing as Disney World okay and I don't
know what oh my God this is a great one
we have Matt Walsh is with us we have
one more Story the dog is asleep on me I
don't care let's do this damn thing all
right we'll be right back more dumb
people down right after this boom
hey townies welcome back to the show I
am going to take us home with Matt Walsh
before you do that I want to remind
everybody our patreon is only five bucks
a month yes we do green leaves on there
we tell personal stories down there
we're eventually gonna do some dumbass
eating challenge it is a safe haven for
dumb including your own you can email
dptpod gmail.com and send us any dumb
story from your life that you witnessed
or you know about maybe some family lore
it's a great good time and it's only
five bucks a month we'll do a Jersey
Mike's Jimmy John's Subway food
challenge yeah we'll do it or freeze the
cake and see who's gonna eat the whole
thing yes we'll do it eat the whole
thing eat the whole thing challenge oh
whoever yes if someone loses a bet
uh here's what we'll do Dan you know the
hot chip challenge we are supposed to
chip in the world if we get to a
thousand patreon people Randy and I are
gonna try the hottest I'm going to as
well and whoever lasts the least amount
of time I think you gotta chase it with
the cake the cake is how we calm down
I'll do it at 500 so that then I can
commentate when you guys do it at a
thousand yeah are going to kill each
other okay you ready for this this one
was sent in by a great uh person who
sends stuff in this is uh Matthew
Friedman at not your average man AVG
Matt not your AVG mat okay ready send in
this is back in December here's the
headline Florida man arrested after
posing uh as Disney World employee and
stealing Star Wars R2D2 replica whoa I
mean this guy's going after him more
than DeSantis right he's like on the
inside
you ever go to have you ever been to
Adam Savages like after party at
sketchfest where it's like though his
his
he has an R2D2 in there that's a set
R2D2 that he still is that is going to
the Smithsonian he also has a whole
bunch of Indiana Jones things and oh my
God God bless him his trust level in
comics none of the cabinets are locked
yeah and so you better lock that stuff I
got a couple other Comics to be like we
have to see how heavy remember the
sandbag to the thing I'm like we have to
see how heavy it really is
you have to put something else of equal
weight dude an alarm went off and then I
got shot with a dart by Alfred Molina
and the snake came out of his mouth
right okay Florida man has been arrested
after he posed as a Disney World
employee and stole a we're going to talk
about how much it cost replica of the
iconic Star Wars R2D2 character ABC
Central uh Florida affiliate w f TV for
the win for the VIN uh reports that
David Emerson proudfoot maybe the best
name is David Emerson
there's a lot of things he hasn't stolen
but just you weighed just you by the way
David Emerson outfit it's to me it's
like could this be like a
Emerson Lake and Palmer Native American
spin-off like they did they had a group
that tried to sue dep wait so here's the
best R2D2 bit ever stand up bid Felipe
Esparza I'm going to give him all the
credit in the world it is a bit that it
makes me laugh so so hard that he said
it's like RT I gotta we want to do it
it's his bit but I would say go find it
worth it worth the search just that R2D2
is Hispanic definitely Mexican that's
all we need to know he makes a great
premise I did all this man all those
noises he made
just brilliant all right so uh of
Kissimmee Kissimmee yeah uh was arrested
on May 31st after he snatched the Droid
from Disney World Swan Hotel in an
attempt to get hired as a security guard
at Walt Disney World in Orlando Florida
so was he gonna snatch it and then look
what I said what I found oh maybe the
crazy thing is even being employee
there'd be a there'd be some point at a
checkpoint or something where someone
would go where are you going with that
so that's a big well but okay so
according to Belize proudfoot was seen
by hotel security pushing a cart on he
got all the way as soon property oh cart
on property while wearing an orange work
vest in a Disney World Riddler tag I
mean he made a name tag sure or maybe he
went to the gift shop
I have one someone had got one that says
Daniel it was like at a thrift shop or
whatever and they gave it to me and I
will tell you firsthand they frown on
you wearing an employee name tag if you
are not one yeah it's just to wear it to
the park when you go to the park yeah
security guards who suspected something
suspicious was taking place subsequently
escorted proudfoot to the yacht club
resort to retrieve his belongings and
driver's license from the employees
lockers so they're like all right now
let's see what it is at which point
Disney officials called law enforcement
proudfoot allegedly told police he had
been he had a pending application with
Walt Disney World security and was only
moving I'm pre-hired I'm only moving the
R2D2 replica in an effort to show
weakness in the security of the resort
so he's like I'm stress testing this
thing this is the guy who heard that a
hacker ended up being hired by the FBI
yeah and he was like he watched Catch Me
If You Can twice it was like you need
this if I'm I'm cheating with your wife
to show you how much you don't
appreciate her you better watch it okay
so with the hope of Landing a job at the
resort he also later admitted to
breaking into three separate arcade
machines at Disney's Wilderness you know
what yeah that seems off topic right not
really testing security at that point uh
Matt that was that was for him vandalous
sometimes he does one for him that's not
what I do he did it at the Wilderness
Lodge the boardwalk Resort and the Grand
Floridian Florida I called it so he said
Grand Floridian three separate resorts
to just show them look yeah I can break
into these things just to get some
quarters is that what's going on is that
the prize who has the high score I just
that's it
everyone is proud foot
um
proud fit sorry proudfoot had the dog
just literally laid on readjusted do you
know how to do anything no I'm good
proudfoot uh I just anytime I say
proudfoot it makes me laugh I feel like
you're talking about Land Before Time
he's been charged with two counts of
Grand Theft one count of petty of petite
theft okay petite theft is so cute it's
a little bit it's like when you want the
steak but you want the
this is the Droid you're looking for I'm
sorry
do you think that he said that uh he'd
he tried uh that people tried to stop
him from leaving the park uh and he said
that all right so one kind of
obstruction by false information and one
count of scheming to defraud this guy
yeah
was he claiming his plan was to get
caught so he could tell them when they
stopped him he said you did it guys I
currently have an application with
security congratulations show you how
good I'm gonna be at this job I wanted
to show you the flaws
that's exactly what he said shouldn't I
be hired now but if they hadn't stopped
him how do we know he wasn't going to
leave I know that but he was just moving
it okay I mean but he was going to then
put it back maybe after he successfully
strip it and sell it for parts on
tattooing that's the only that's my only
thing I could do that the Star Wars boar
bar the alley behind the Cheesecake
Factory where I mean where do you sell
the extra parts but that is really to me
all right so let's figure out a how old
is this guy what was this a proud give
me the name full name Emerson David
Emerson David Emerson the third I'm just
trying to date it with maybe David
Emerson proudfoot is how old well you
have to be dumb to think that's gonna
work right
this is like uh
this is like people who commit a crime
then be like oh no there's a letter in
my car that says I'm actually 41. 41.
okay
29. Daniel
sweetness 34. 34. get your answers in
townies because David Emerson proudfoot
is
44 years old
there's something about older people
that makes me think of security well she
she left yeah
[Music]
she's gonna tell me I can't pull
something off she left he's never
amounted to anything but The Young
Person's gonna want a more lively job
that's right like right it's more
sedentary to be standard and uh an older
person feels like they can be like look
I'm just trying to work you know I'm
helping me like like no I just want to
touch I'm helping you guys out yeah I'm
helping you out I'm helping you guys
reaching you all right now do we want
kid runs let's let's venture to guess
how and this is what we'll get value on
this how the value of the R2D2 replica
that he was trying to get walk out is
there a hologram that comes out of it it
was set up in some hotel right it was on
display yeah Grand Floridian I mean put
it in a cart with an orange vest on
tried to walk it out of there oh I
missed that is that real you said that
he put an orange vest on our Channel
you think he brought the card he just
took a hotel he took a hotel oh like the
luggage car yeah okay okay where do you
want to go okay you want to go first
take or third I'll go last I'm like okay
I'll go first so what do you think go
ahead I'm gonna go 17 000 17 grand I'm
gonna say thirty four thousand dollars
that's a real thing there you go
um yeah I mean I'll say what'd you say
seven I'll say 21 21 000 all right get
your answers in town okay again the name
of the podcast so people can subscribe
and love let's talk subscribe and love
it Matt Walsh so they can check it out
going back and through all the uh Veep
episodes and giving you a little uh
Easter eggs and tidbits and stories of
what happened behind the scenes with Tim
Simons I'm sure people like me
it's a great idea so I'm going to be
subscribing to that and you guys should
too uh this R2D2 replica was
ten thousand dollars Daniel very nice it
doesn't have to have any functionality
and it's a replica yeah they crank them
out still by the way 10 grand is a lot
10 grand is a lot yeah you shouldn't
think you're getting away with that you
shouldn't think you could walk so you
tried to roll a bb-8 out of there and
also it's on display in the hotel so it
can't be they know people are going to
try to take right they're not gonna time
like crown jewels time of day is
everything with a hotel you either want
to do like two in the morning and be
like maintenance we can't do this when
there's we steal it during during
chaos that's right yeah and you look
official and you look like you know what
you're doing they asked me to come down
yeah actually what you really should
have gone in the day before put a sign
on it that said uh like flagged flagged
for repair and then be like I'm gonna
come back tomorrow and grab this we
gotta okay I hope we had a clipboard
that just it's just a little more I need
you to decide
no you don't want to engage and you're
bringing suspicions no you need an old
Bluetooth that you keep talking to me
cool like in everything everywhere all
at once yeah yeah uh all right now I
want to steal a tiger from Vegas
well what do they display in the Vegas
lobbies I feel like you've given me how
to do it yeah yeah yeah but Vegas has
probably better security than that I
think the second you live Vegas they can
shoot and Tackle you yeah yeah they're
probably tracking you the minute you go
in there's a camera in the tiger you're
trying to steal so forget it it's a
GoPro if you find out it's a replica
tiger too when you get it it's like I so
wanted there to be a small security like
a kid who's a security guard to be
inside R2D2 is like oh [__] hey hey
there you go that's the show Matt Walsh
thank you for doing it with us
appreciate you love you and uh oh [__]
we got to get back to work
town
[Music]